Hey, this is Clark and I want to remind you that this podcast is brought to you by ScoutmasterCGcom
Backers. The funds we get from our backers cover the expenses of producing and publishing
everything at ScoutmasterCGcom, including what you're about to listen to. Go to ScoutmasterCGcom
and click the support link at the top of the page and you can join hundreds of your fellow
Scouters who help me keep the podcast freely available for Scouters all over the world.
Have you heard Kevin Callan, author and Canadian canoe and camping enthusiast? Kevin's written a
new book. It's called Days, But Not Confused- Tales of a Wilderness Traveler. I came across this.
I think this is a good rule to apply to see if your trip is an adventure or not. If a trip isn't
long enough to require the use of a toilet trowel, it's not a real trip.
If you have to use the toilet trowel, that means you're in the woods long enough for it to
be an adventure. Thanks, Kevin. Hey, this is podcast number 164..
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster Podcast. This is Clark Green. Let's take a look in the mailbag-
Pretty full this week. Stephen Kaminski, assistant scoutmaster with Troop 869 in Midlothian,
Virginia, writes in to say: I just got back from a scoutmaster leader training
the outdoor portion this past weekend in the heart of Virginia Council.
My first night was uncomfortable, sleeping in my camp-issued canvas tent while the temperature
was 28 degrees. My second night was downright cozy, as one of the members of my patrol let me an
additional sleeping bag. As an adult, I was quickly reminded of the effect that kindness has,
no matter what our age. In this case, I happily found it most difficult to get out of my cocoon
of sleeping bags the next morning. While I'm just getting into the Boy Scout side of
scouting, I've already shared your patrol leader information with my new patrol leader and his
assistants. I've also done my best to drop a hint or two about your podcasts and website,
as it's done its job to remind me why we put ourselves into these uncomfortable situations
on purpose. Thank you for your insight and willingness to share your experience with those
of us out here, helping to make a difference and help the scouts we are working with become men.
I make it a point to queue up your current or past podcasts as I leave the driveway on my
weekday commute to work. Once I do, I find it difficult to pause the podcast until I return
to it later that afternoon. Thanks again, and here's hoping you can continue your good work.
And thank you, Steve. It's always great to hear from folks and know that they're listening
and getting something from the podcast. I really appreciate you being in touch.
I had this email from George Aegon and George is in Manahawk in New Jersey with Troop 61.
Since I read your blog a few times this week and I always agree with your take on things,
I periodically send links to my assistant scoutmasters. have them check out something
that relates to an issue or an event in our troop. Thanks very much for putting yourself out there
and thank you, George, for getting in touch. I'm glad to hear from you.
Over on iTunes, Doug Marks left a five-star review that says Clark has great information
and really makes you think about how best to serve the scouts. Thank you so much, Doug.
Heard from Penny Neal. Penny is up to her eyeballs in Fintcastle, Virginia.
She's a commissioner for three packs and three troops. She's an adult volunteer with a crew,
a troop and a pack, with a son who's an Eagle Scout and two grandsons and cub scouts.
She wrote to say I enjoyed the pioneering sculpture pictures and I will show them
around my troops and crew. What fun. And yes, they do look like a lot of fun. If you haven't seen that
yet, go to scoutmasterscgcom, Look for a recent post called pioneering unleashed and take a look.
It's hard to explain, so make sure you get over there and take a look at it.
We also heard from Daniel Desjardins in Litchfield, New Hampshire. He said:
just started to listen to the original podcast, I'm up to number 26 now. I enjoy the great
content. Keep it coming. Well, thank you, Daniel. I really appreciate it
And, Bolchanse, being a new scoutmaster in training, It's great to hear from you.
In this podcast and scoutmastership: in seven minutes or less, we're going to talk a little bit
about 23 leadership questions. Now, this was a post that we put up on the blog a week or so ago
and we're going to go over it here on the podcast, And then we have an email question
answer And that's going to fill up the rest of the podcast. So let's get started, shall we?
Scoutmastership in seven minutes or less.
So one of the things I do, and probably one of the things you do too, is spend a fair amount of
time thinking and reading and studying about leadership and just what the heck that is.
You can find a lot of information out there a lot of books and a lot of definitions, And
I kind of have made it my task to try and boil all that down into something that I think is simple
and direct and understandable for our youth leaders. How do you convey the message
of leadership to them? How do you talk to them about it in a way that they'll find compelling
and interesting and engaging and where they'll begin to understand and practice those things?
The best method I've come up with is asking questions, And don't try to provide all the
answers, but provide a lot of questions and get them thinking. Then things will start to click.
Developing leadership takes some time. It can't be condensed down into a course of study or
a special leadership training weekend or something like that. While those things may be helpful,
the only real way to learn to lead is just to get out there and start leading and see what
happens and encounter the disappointments and the setbacks and the difficulties and learn
to move past them and develop those skills. Now we had a leadership challenge weekend a
couple of weeks ago for our older scouts. One of the tools we used was a self-evaluation
with a set of questions, And the way we use this tool is. we gave the scouts this leadership
self-evaluation sheet. We said: find a quiet place and sit down and rate yourself on how well you
answer these questions. And we did that early on. We did that the Friday night of the weekend
And then, after they had been through some challenges and exercises all day on Saturday,
we asked them to go back and try that again. I never saw one of those sheets. I didn't see
how anybody filled it out. This was not a way to score people against a perfect mean
or to compare them to each other. It was a self-evaluation tool just to get them thinking,
to understand some of the various components of what being a leader really means. But the idea
was to get them to go back after this leadership challenge weekend and see if they had improved
anywhere. Then we sat down and we had a reflection and discussion around a campfire And they mentioned
some of the different things that they thought they had improved on. Now I made this the subject
of a post on the blog a week or so ago. Let me go through and talk about the major kind of leadership
competencies that these questions are based on. I will tell you I borrowed very extravagantly
from materials published by the National Outdoor Leadership School. These are absolutely
derivative of some of their conceptualizations of leadership, And the first set of questions
was based on leadership behavior. How well do you treat everyone with dignity and respect?
How well do you help others at all times And how well do you admit to and correct your
mistakes? Sitting down and answering those questions- that's not an easy thing to do,
especially if you're 13 or 14 or 15.. But if you sit and you start thinking about those,
it will begin to highlight your strengths and also the things that you need to work on.
There's a basic overall personal competence that a leader needs And that's based on these
questions: How well do you know and apply scout skills? I mean, if you're pretty weak in that,
that's something to develop because it's going to be necessary for you to work with those skills
throughout every level of scouting. How well do you set goals and follow through
And how well do you pay attention to others? That's just kind of this basic competency of
knowing and being aware of what's going on around you. Communication is another key leadership
competency. How well do you give and get directions and information? How well do you inform
others as situations change? Now that one. there's a lot of weight there. There's a lot in that.
so far as being a leader, How well do you inform others as situations change? How well do you
listen actively? How well do you ask questions if you don't understand? Being a good leader
means having an advanced sense of good judgment and decision making. So how well do you use all
resources and information? How well do you understand clear limits and boundaries?
How well do you know what matters to others? All of the answers to those questions are going to
gauge how you make judgments and decisions. How well do you know what matters to the
people that you're leading? I mean you can't make a good judgment, You can't make a good decision,
without knowing that. The next term that identifies this set of questions and this leadership
competency I lifted 100% from the National Outdoor Leadership School and I love it:
Tolerance for adversity and uncertainty. Tolerance for adversity and uncertainty:
I mean if I had to pick somebody out, if it was up to me to choose a leader,
I would be looking for somebody who was tolerant to adversity and uncertainty.
How well do you respond positively when things change? How well do you turn challenge into
opportunity? How well do you endure and enjoy challenge? I mean really the difference between
somebody who is just like a competent manager and somebody who is a competent leader is the way
they respond to adversity and uncertainty. Another important aspect of being a decent leader and
a good follower is self-awareness. I mean, you know, if you'll remember being 13,, 14,
and 15, you were pretty self-aware A lot of times. you didn't put that in the context of being aware
of others and aware what was going on around you. but you can leverage that self-awareness-
the kind of highly attenuated self-awareness that boys have in that age- to begin to get them
to look at other people and to consider the way other people are feeling and what they're aware
of. So how well do you understand your abilities and limitations? How well do you learn from experience
and improve? How well do you hold yourself accountable If you do those things well for
yourself, if you have that self-awareness that can be expanded to helping others develop that
kind of awareness and also encouraging that kind of group awareness- The last leadership
competency that was vision and action- How well do you use your initiative to make things happen?
How well do you figure out what needs to be done and do it? How well do you encourage and help
others? So these 23 questions, like I said, we use them during our Leadership Challenge weekend
just as a self-evaluation, just as a way to get guys started thinking. But this is also the
source of 23 great Scoutmaster Minutes. This is also the source of a great two-minute
end of the Petrolators Council meeting question that you can take and you can ask and begin a
discussion that way. This is also a good tool to use when you're kind of doing that
after-action reflection. You know you've had a meeting or you've had an outing
and you sit down and say, okay, guys, so let's go through and ask ourselves how well we
did these things, And I think it'll help focus things. I am certainly not recommending
that you take all these questions and you sit down for an hour and a half and you drill your
youth leaders on them. Do a little bit here and there, Use these as conversation starters,
as reflection starters, and let me know how they work, will you?
No, we need to settle. thrifty, brave, clean and reverent.
A Scout is just a middle-owned foreman, a courier's caddy, a champion-
thrifty, brave, clean and reverent.
I certainly don't need to do this, but I use recordings of some of the people I
interview as a little buff during the program. If you were willing, you could
say: this is Bob Mazooka and you're listening to Clark Green on the Scout
Master podcast. You bet, you bet I'm happy to. This is Bob Mazooka, he's got
exactly the Boy Scouts and you're listening to my buddy, Clark Green,
on the Scout Master podcast and he is doing a fantastic job.
Well, thanks, thanks, Bob. I'll have to play the entire recording so people
don't think I told you to say that, Okay, that's good, that's fine.
Write me a letter, send it by name
Email. that is folks. And here's an answer to one of your emails.
So I got this email from a scout parent and her name is Melissa
and she says this: I am new to the Boy Scout program.
My question or concern is that I am not getting answers to any questions I have.
For instance, my son is attending a merit badge event. He's supposed to
bring a blue card for the counselor to sign. I got the blue cards from the
Scout Master, who did not know they needed to
be signed before he took them back to the merit badge
counselor. I only found out because another
parent told me they needed to be signed by the unit leader.
So now my son took the blue cards to his next meeting to have
the unit leader sign them, but he wouldn't sign them because they were not
filled out, since my son and I did not know that that was necessary.
Is there any kind of a briefing or meeting for parents so that we,
especially those of us with no experience in Boy Scouts,
know what to do or ask, so that others in the future
don't experience what I feel is a lack of needed information?
Well, Melissa, thank you so much for getting in touch and asking a question,
and I feel your pain. I really do. I know that this is
frustrating and I want to help kind of unravel some of this frustration a
little bit. and I'll tell you that usually
you're not going to find a whole lot of information for parents because
that information is going to the scout
and the scout is expected to manage his own advancement
and to pack his own bag and to take care of himself. There's really no
briefings or meetings for parents or really
a whole lot of effort in explaining things to them
in a lot of ways because- and I know, at least in the case of my troop- this
is very intentional and to understand why that is,
we've got to talk about what scouting is trying to do. here.
I encourage parents to get comfortable with the idea of not knowing a whole lot
about what's going on. The whole purpose of what's going on
is to get their scouts to know these things and to find and discover the
answers to these things. It's not that I think parents should be kept in the
dark or keep their noses out of their son's business or
anything like that. It's because we want scouts
to learn to figure these things out on themselves.
So there's immediate goals in scouting, like getting a merit badge,
and then there's these big, broad goals like learning how to look after yourself,
learning how to get information, learning how to go through
the process of getting a merit badge, learning how to approach and talk to
adults who are not your parents, learning how to ask questions.
When we put our scouts out there like that, they
are going to encounter some frustration and some discouragement.
That's where we really need our parents cooperation to help them
overcome that frustration and discouragement. One of my key challenges
as a scout master is getting parents to buy in on this.
They think they know what I'm talking about, but there's really no way they
can actually understand it until they've been through the whole process.
I've watched this happen hundreds of times, literally hundreds of times.
The amount of self-reliance and independence you see develop in your son
is commensurate with the amount that you let go
and let him do for himself. Can I tell you this: my son is now 30
years old and he works for the college he attended in admissions and promotion,
and he will tell you that the one key skill
many new students lack is the ability to navigate through the very
routine things that they are used to having their parents do for them.
And this is, you know, young ladies and young men
who have graduated from high school, who are entering into their freshman year of
college not knowing how to do laundry and not
knowing how to sign up for classes or even the rudiments of managing a
schedule or the skills of self-regulation. Now, not saying that
when he arrived at college for his freshman year that he didn't have
certain challenges and difficulties to overcome,
but he had a base set of skills, mostly developed through scouting
of independence and the ability to find his own way in the world.
If your son decides he wants to go to this merit badge event
that he'll need to have blue cards and things like that,
I wouldn't get the blue cards for him and I wouldn't find out all the
information about how to use blue cards. I start asking him questions.
well, do you need anything when you go to this merit badge event? it says
here's something about a blue card. how do you get a blue card?
oh, I don't know, mom. oh well, have you asked? uh,
have you looked in your scout handbook to see about that? have you asked your
patrol leader or your senior patrol leader or your scout master about that?
how does how you're going to need to figure out how that
worked. you know, when he comes home and he says: hey, we have a camping trip,
here's my permission slip, I need you to sign it and I need to bring some
stuff. well, what stuff do you need to bring?
is it in your scout handbook? have you asked your patrol leader or your
senior patrol leader or your scout master about that? how are you going to pack it?
what are you going to pack it in? is there anything special that you need to
be thinking about? is there any special gear that we need to get for you? and
then let him at it? I mean, let him pack his own bag.
he'll forget something- and you know I still forget stuff,
I mean after 30 plus years of camping- but
he will learn more from the forgetting than if you pack the bag for him.
he's going to get discouraged and he's going to get frustrated
because in a lot of ways this is not easy. at first blush it seems a little harsh
or it may look like you're not being a responsible parent, and that is an odd
feeling for most of us. it's a difficult feeling.
thing is you'll soon see him start to figure things out more and more.
you'll find that your job is not so much
doing as asking questions and helping him discover answers.
help him look past the initial frustrations and overcome the reluctance
and fear that most boys have and asking questions of
anybody about anything, especially somebody like a scout master who can
often be kind of a daunting figure, and soon
he'll start to ask the questions himself. he'll
absolutely shock you the amount of things that he can do
and you'll see this not only be applied in scouting but you'll see it start to spread
through every aspect of his character and his life.
my advice to parents is to step back, be supportive and understanding and
cooperate with the bigger processes at work.
look for teachable moments. help your scouts figure out what to do next.
not by supplying all the answers or knowing all the answers,
but by asking questions. sounds simple, doesn't it?
of course it does, but it's not.
it's one of the hardest challenges that you're going to meet as a parent.
interesting thing about scouting is it's not just an opportunity for scouts to
learn and grow. it's also an opportunity for adult
volunteers to learn and grow and for their parents to learn and grow.
i went through this process. it was uncomfortable,
it was challenging, but ultimately it was very rewarding.
and remember, i was the scout master, so i knew
everything. and man trying not to provide all the answers
and letting the boy figure these things out on his own-
that could be a real challenge at times. i honestly hope that helps
and i honestly hope that i haven't offended the sensibilities of any
parents who are listening out there. but i'll just repeat one more time.
there are some specific goals in scouting that are very easy to
understand, like getting a merit badge or getting your next rank or going on a
camping trip or something like that. but those
are all tangential. they're not the real goal. the real goal is developing
competent, self-confident, self-starting human beings
with a lot of compassion and initiative, not only to help themselves but to
help other people. if you catch that vision
and you start working with your son in scouting
in that wise, i think that you will get some results
that will be well worth the initial discomfort
and the initial kind of difficult feeling that you have in letting them go.
i've seen it happen hundreds and hundreds of times
and i could tell you that it works. you could get in touch and send me an
email question, and you're going to find out how to do that in just a
moment.
well, thanks for listening. here's how to keep in touch.
read the scoutmaster blog at scoutmastercgcom.
you can subscribe there to receive updates to the blog by email.
you can also subscribe to the scoutmaster podcast on itins
and you can access this podcast on your mobile device through stitcher smart
radio. you can get details about how to do that
at stitchercom. you can experience all the wonders of
scoutmastercgcom through the vast panorama
of social media outlets. follow us at scoutmaster blog on facebook.
tweet scoutmastercg on twitter and, for admittance to the exclusive scoutmastercg
circle, search for scoutmastercg on google plus.
if the vast panorama of social media does not amaze and thrill you,
you can always email me. it's easy, right? my email address is clark
clarkie at scoutmastercgcom. that's clark
clarkie at scoutmastercgcom. it only remains for me to tell you
that the scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster podcast are not official
publications of the Boy Scouts of America.
nope, they're not endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America either. no,
it's just me with a microphone trying to lend a hand to scout leaders. and,
you know, have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun, we always like to hear from our founder, sir
robert. bin. pal, sir robert.
good luck to you and group camping why? thank you, sir,
until next time
you.